[Musique]
situé au pied du mont royal sur l'avenue
des pins en plein coeur du golden square
mile
c'est cette propriété méconnu à
l'histoire extraordinaire qui pourrait
devenir la plus chère jamais vendue au
québec la courtière liza kaufman décrit
la maison bâtie en 1926 comme un palace
italien de la renaissance
et pour cause les plafonds ont été
conçus par des artisans venus d'italie
les foyers qui date du 14ème siècle ont
été importées d'italie
tout comme l'illustrent et on retrouve
aussi se bat fabriqué à sienne pour
nulle autre que le pape
la reine elizabeth a quant à elle dormi
dans cette chambre laisser identique
depuis son passage
la propriété a été construite pour john
mcenroe un industriel montréalais qui a
fait fortune dans le sucre
tacopina musique
les propriétaires actuels ont acheté la
maison il y a une vingtaine d'années ils
ont investi 20 millions $ pour la
restaurer mais comme leurs enfants
quitteront bientôt le nid familial
le manoir de 32 mille pieds carrés
comptant 60 ces pièces dont douze
chambres et huit salles de bains
deviendra trop grand il est en vente
pour 29 millions 900 mille dollars
trois acheteurs potentiels se sont
manifestés
une annexe sur twitter qu à la fin
depuis dix ans les ventes de maisons de
luxe ont quintuplé au québec en 2010 486
propriétés d'une valeur de 1 million $
et plus ont été vendus dans la province
le nombre de transactions a augmenté
chaque année par la suite pour atteindre
2400 en 2020 avec les prix qui montent
tranquillement mais de plus en plus
propriété qui vont se classer dans un
million et plus et donc le nombre de
transactions la station privée va
augmenter mais la pandémie a aussi un
impact
le nombre de propriétés de luxe vendus à
l'extérieur du grand montréal a bondi de
10% l'an dernier les plus fortunés sont
attirés eux aussi par les arpents verts
on avait un intérêt pour les propriétés
avec des grands terrains des bords de
l'eau vraiment plus le secteur
villégiature qui étaient en forte
demande cette année
liza kaufman croit qu'elle n'aura pas de
difficulté à vendre la propriété de
l'avenue des pins un véritable joyau
selon elle avis aux intéressés
les offres sont toujours acceptés ici
olivier bachar radio canada montréal